so if you two want to sit here will
scores be safe when they reopen two more
pupils staff at this primary school in
Birmingham are among those who have
their doubts lots of teachers have been
in school throughout the lockdown
offering child care for key workers
we've seen firsthand how difficult
children of finding social distancing
staff are concerned that they could
potentially pick up the virus and
children become unwell themselves and
then take it home to their own families
Thank You Lois after a meeting with the
government scientific advisors teaching
unions say they've been left with more
questions than answers schools across
England currently do not have the advice
and the guidance they need to be
absolutely certain that they can open as
safely as possible the government
guidance accepts that primary eight
children can't be expected to always
stay two metres apart from one another
so the idea is that they'll be divided
into groups of no more than 15 and that
each group will be kept apart from other
children in the school some schools have
already said they will reopen the
founder of one Academy trust argues
concern about coronavirus has to be
balanced against the harm to
disadvantaged children of missing school
we've been concerned about them being
locked in inadequate housing under sized
we've been concerned about them not
getting out not socialising not being
able to exercise not engaging in any
kind of education and not eating well
the education secretary said getting
children back to school is vital for
their educational development and many
schools are already taking steps to
welcome back their pupils I'm grateful
for their support but parents aren't all
convinced I think everyone wants their
children to go back to school but
everyone wants it to be safe that that's
top priority really it just surprises me
that children who were so young are
being sent back to school
because they're the least likely to be
able to socially distance rolled dice to
see who have got the highest number the
government has more work to do to
persuade teachers it's the right
decision Becky Johnson Sky News
Birmingham